[موسيقى]
هذه هي المرة الأولى التي تعير فيها
مكتبة الكونجرس
عنصرًا من مجموعتها
إلى أي معرض
على الإطلاق
، وهذا ما يجعل هذا الأمر فريدًا للغاية
، والغرض من عرض
نسخة توماس جيفرسون من القرآن
في المعرض العالمي
هو
إظهار
ذلك  في بداية هذه الأمة
، عرف أحد المؤسسين
أن البلاد
بحاجة إلى
قادة سينظرون في جميع أنواع
القوانين
والسياسات من جميع أنحاء العالم
وكان القرآن أحد
العناصر التي كان يعلم أنه بحاجة إليها لدراسة
توماس جيفرسون
[موسيقى  ]
تكون
[موسيقى
] طريقة إحضار هذا القرآن
إلى المعرض العالمي مشابهة لما
كان سيحدث لو
تم إحضار لوحة الموناليزا إلى هذا المعرض ، كان عليك أن
يكون لديك
متخصصون في الترميم والحفظ قاموا بفحص الحالة
قبل أن يغادر
الصناديق المصممة خصيصًا  وعربات
نقل وحشو خاصة بالنقل الجوي
بأمان خاص مع
حافظة
مصاحبة للقرآن وضعها في علبة
مصممة خصيصًا بها أجهزة استشعار  التي
تراقب الرطوبة والهواء وأي
حركة ،
كل شيء عن نقل
وتركيب هذه المنحة يجب أن يكون
مميزًا وفريدًا.
هذه النسخة من القرآن
كانت في الواقع جزءًا من مجموعة توماس جيفرسون
التي تم بيعها إلى الولايات المتحدة
بعد حريق
في العاصمة  في حرب عام 1812. كان لدى
توماس جيفرسون رئيسنا الثالث
أكبر مجموعة
شخصية مكتبة في الولايات المتحدة في ذلك
الوقت ،
لذلك كان هذا القرآن جزءًا من 6000 مجلد
كان توماس جيفرسون قد
اندلع فيه حريق آخر على الرغم من أنه
في عام 1851 عشية عيد الميلاد
واثنين  -ثالث تلك المجموعة الأصلية
التي أعطاها توماس جيفرسون تم
تدميرها ولكن ليس القرآن
، وبالتالي فإن تفرد
بقاء هذا القرآن هو مجرد شيء
يسعدنا جدًا أن نعرضه لك على
[موسيقى]
جيفرسون